one of the moments on the State of the
Union address that everyone's been
talking about was a president Trump
honoring conservative radio host Rush
Limbaugh with the highest civilian honor
a president can bestow the Presidential
Medal of Freedom take a look I am proud
to announce tonight that you will be
receiving our country's highest civilian
honor the Presidential Medal of Freedom
rush limbaugh yeah now it
now it used to be that the Presidential
Medal of Freedom was a very hard thing
to get in the past it went to people
like mother Teresa got a Presidential
Medal Freedom Civil Rights icon Rosa
Parks got one so yeah so a lot of people
are saying that they're giving it to
Rush Limbaugh's what's kind of lowering
the bar for such a great honor but the
way I see it you know Trump loves
handing these medals out and I noticed
it seems to make people happy to get one
of these metals it just does and you saw
Rush Limbaugh I was thrilled mm-hmm so
maybe it's us maybe we're being too
fussy with who gets these medals maybe
Trump has the right idea which is why
ladies and gentlemen I've decided to
give everyone in my audience the
presidential
[Applause]
wait
exciting indeed great I got to I'm gonna
make one into a belt buckle
that's fantastic
hey who wants what presidential
yeah
[Applause]
even though we're a tune in the rafters
gets one
[Music]
great show star the Netflix series
narcos mexico diego luna's here
put me right back
[Music]